n ça sera après noël ça s'appellera
joyeuses pâques voici pierre arditi demi
jean la cyberattaque non mais j'ai un
dossier sur pierre à la vache via vous
êtes né à paris le 1er décembre 1944
on traînait pas ça sent pas bon je vais
pourquoi tu es un dinosaure thierry
surtout c'est parce que c'est mon fils
gaston il dit toujours papa dans
l'émission mais vachement bien y'a pas
de dinosaures donc maintenant j'ai un
dinosaure pour gascon voilà tu ferais
bien qu'ils restaient bien que cette
année sur le thème des dinosaures alors
un pierre gritti ça fait une paye qu'on
vous a pas vu c'est quand même temps
vous a pas vu à la télé je sais pas ça
peut peut-être un an et demi un an et
demi c'est ça vous avez pas changé c'est
toujours aussi élégant et vous retrouver
david ayer des prix d'élégance
monsieur longines à une grande soirée au
ritz j'ai fait deuxième
oui ils ont tous les deux viennent
d'ailleurs et il a compris un truc car
dit il on essaie d'y en art 10 ans il a
un prix d'élégance facile se répètent le
contraire est bas mais non mais c'est le
contraire les vieux puits est beaucoup
plus encore je m'habille comme ça
l'année prochaine je me dirais arditi
sur un fil élégance pendant molière et
le poids quand ça va vous coûter chez
pas dites moi non ça va déjà bien quoi
padres le visage est bien là non c'est
pas mal
franchement là c'est le maintien mais je
vous regarde moi beaucoup savez je
regarde très baissier parce que le
problème en fait c'est ça c'est ça avec
le bois que vous n'avez absolument rien
si j'ai apprécié je mets profil c'est
alors donc j'étais en tournée en france
c'est pour ça qu'on voit pas beaucoup à
la télé parce que vous travaillez
vraiment sérieusement la très sérieuse
très sérieusement depuis combien de
temps je n'entends tournai et joyeuse ça
le troisième mois à oui alors joyeuses
pâques donc moi c'est une pièce de jean
poiret évidemment on va en parler tout
de suite mais d'abord vous savez il ya
un petit rituel dans cette émission
c'est comment on fait
voilà les plus grands acteurs le fond je
dis ça pour arnaud montebourg qui n'a
pas voulu le faire voilà à pierre arditi
cta grands comédiens français le énorme
inauguré voilà c'est du lourd la grande
mouvement il le fait bien
alors c'est à partir du 16 janvier 2001
au théâtre des variétés mises en scène
de votre ami bernard murat avec caroline
silhol et barbara shoot est le signe
d'une commis de jean poiret je vais
raconter le pitch si vous voulez oui
c'est moi ce qui est bien avec moins
fait le pcci la différence avec d'autres
animateurs
si vous êtes obligés d'aller vendre
votre pièce par exemple moi je fais tout
sauf montebourg il a fait était gentil
je vais pas vendu son vieux alors c'est
sa fille qui est jouée par caroline
silhol donc qui part pour le week-end de
pâques et stéphane c'est vous son mari
en profite pour inviter une jeune fille
s'appelle julie qui est jouée par
barbara schulz mais il ya des grèves
d'avion c'est drôle comme c'est une
vraie comédie à la feydeau à cette
histoire
et alors elle revient elle revient ciel
elle revient et elle trouve son mari
stéphane vous avec la jeune fille
voilà et qu'est ce que vous dites est ce
moment-là qu'est ce que vous faites à ce
moment là et bien à ce moment là ce
explique avec un aplomb absolument
colossal que c'est ma fille
voilà dans premier vice- la première
voilà c'est ensuite une fois que le
doigt et mis dans cet engrenage là c'est
à dire dans ce dans ce début de
mensonges
il pousse le mensonge jusqu'à la folie
km h que la folie c'est un petit peu le
mécanisme du tailleur pour dames qui est
aussi l'histoire d'un menteur qui se
fait pour les jouer aussi oui c'est joué
seulement il ya 15 ans
spécialisé dans tout ça hein ça me plaît
bien rassurez-vous sagement vous passez
de beckett a fait doux assez facilement
moi je pense que mon métier c'est de
jouer tout se sait pas jouer tout c'est
de jouer les auteurs qui sont dignes de
ce nom à voir est aussi digne d'être
joué que beckett du guitry que feydeau
que grimbert que yasmina reza que tout
le reste c'est malin alors donc ça
commence le 16 janvier au théâtre des
variétés qui appartient à jean paul
belmondo jean paul simon gars j'ai joué
le rôle est il agirait si brice oui
c'était parce qu'il a fait mieux
bah sinon c'est dans une ambiance on
était dans une environnement tranquille
on était au pénal leur film de belmondo
on peut le dire ou c'est tabou c'est
tabou alors on alors c'est un excellent
tin oo la télémaintenance et verrouiller
un attention
alors vous le principe de votre jeu
d'acteur c'est cette puiser en vous à
travers des expériences personnelles
pour les retranscrire sur scène ou à
l'écran et des fois c'est des choses
très privé dont vous nourrissez vos
personnages vous faites appel à votre
mémoire affective ça c'est votre façon
de huy pas à leur métier d'acteur oui
pas seulement enfin observer c'est ce
qu'on appelle la méthode stanislavski n
est oui alors je le dis à nos amis et
spectateurs ces deux services publics
dans les bars stanislavski acteur et
metteur en scène russe 1863 1938
animateurs du théâtre d'art de moscou
cheyrou 1 à nice est donc là les
metteurs en scène d'antoine tchekhov
entre autres est bon et je sais pas ma
méthode à moi c'est que je crois pour le
vivre maintenant depuis 35 ans qui
finalement on ne fait que jouer des
petits morceaux de soi même au fur pour
des personnages qu'on est con et sans
ses interprètes et au long d'une vie
évidemment le but c'est de prendre à
l'intérieur de soi des choses qu'on peut
connaître de la mettre au service de
quelqu'un qui n'est pas soi voilà il
faut très longtemps pour un pour le
comprendre et deux pour savoir le faire
y compris à ses vices et les chefs
comment il fallait quand on joue une
pièce qu'ils ne correspond à rien de ce
qu'on a vécu
y'a rien qui ne correspond pas justement
il ya toujours un moment où on va les
prendre comme ça ok tiens ça veut dire
que vous ai jamais vécu comment j'ai
fait là parce que la socgen est arrivé
vous de tromper votre femme pendant ça
m'est arrivé en tire
l'arrivée de mme antier mais cette
histoire est une manière de mentir par
exemple kiné qui pourrait par un certain
instant ma véhémence peut me servir de
vérité par exemple comme souvent chez
les gens qui manquent donc je me sers de
cette véhémence dans le mensonge vont
nourrir ce personnage qui lui est
pratiquement à mende
acculé être un menteur professionnel
pour ça qu'on peut le trouver chez moi
est ce qu'on va passer des choses plus
intimes
elle le sait
une brique ce que vous avez déjà été
magne j'ai déjà été m'arrive d'un enfant
le segment b mais qu'il est bête ce
garçon mais qu'il est plus mis la mort
sinon on le sait maintenant comme il m'a
chassé sur wii là parce que j'essayais
de comprendre comment vous avez pu vous
mettre dans la peau de ce stéphane en
fait vous êtes arrivé cette histoire
vous avez eu un enfant avant votre
mariage y parvenir il m'est arrivé une
certaine époque d'être obligé de mentir
pour des raisons comme celle-là oui sans
pour autant faire passer la jeune fille
en question pour ma fille bien sûr bien
alors ni pour ta mère va sur mer encore
moi alors une bonne nouvelle donc
d'abord il ya évidemment les variétés le
16 janvier puis ensuite le 5 juillet
vous fait l'ouverture du festival
d'avignon dans la grande cour mais fait
pas le blasé comme ça ça chez ab ça non
mais pas de la liste que jamais a
beaucoup oui oui surtout que c'est
l'école des femmes
oui qe2 rien bien février la chance à
susurrer des fois ça arrive quoi que ce
soit encore des bruits une émission
culturelle donc vous jouez arnal
évidemment évidemment vous avez un
succès tardif vous oui hein vous trouvez
vous par rapport à jordy oui c'est vrai
mais c'est un mal d'ailleurs il est
temps de vous construire mais le temps
de vous et avant j'ai fait mon métier je
me suis construit je me suis identifié
moi je pense la première premier devoir
est le premier travail de l'acteur c'est
d'abord savoir qui il est rond pouvoir
reproduire les autres bons tous et on
l'a mal servi à ça ça m'a servi à vivre
c'est-à-dire à constituer un morceau de
vie et de ma vie qui me sert aujourd'hui
de matériau de travail quand je contrôle
mais ce que je veux dire sa peine il
fait un temps et puis voilà c'est pas
venu c'est pas venu d'un coup pourtant
vous êtes allés au spectacle à ces
jeunes c'est dans le monde du spectacle
assez jeune et puisque votre père était
peintre il peut ya dix jours il vient
toujours et toujours vivant et
pagesjaunes dit dans nos îles à 80,6
mais bon le salut si tu le regardes il
va nous regarder nous regarde
salut papa bon anniversaire voilà
alors vous viviez dans une grande maison
rue dallée rue des martyrs où il est
plein de monde essaie de lui vous a
poussé vers un métier créatif votre père
ça c'est rare mais pas ce que vous dites
avec lui tu es pas question d'être
fonctionnaire ou ingénieur oui ce qui
était encore plus rare à l'époque
aujourd'hui parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
devenu à la mode tous les tous les
gamins ont envie de devenir chanteur
acteur à l'époque c'était pas très bien
vu remplissent votre famille que j'avais
des cousins avec les cannetti il ya un
prix nobel chez les canetti mais les
gars disent il s'allume prix nobel de
littérature en littérature arabe à lille
et ma mission culturelle met donc
qu'elle ait dit oui
jacques canetti cas les découvreurs de
tout le monde oui qui avait un endroit
absolument formidable qui n'existe plus
aujourd'hui que s'appeler qui s'appelait
trois beaux des femmes au début j'ai vu
moi débuté petit garçon moi petit garçon
gainsbourg brel
fernand raynaud raymond devos bon
c'était faber avait 7 ans béart je vais
très très bien doté 15 e téra charles ix
à l'époque quand même un vrai choc mais
il était jeune il était absolument
magnifique il y avait les cheveux tout à
fait rare un empattement ton du haras il
avait ses grandes oreilles en chou-fleur
je me souviendrai toute ma vie il avait
un magnifique costume prince de galles
avec un col roulé gris perle et des
pompes pointues en été dans des jardins
ralentit très dense et il était
absolument magnifique qui chantait
génial et un jour votre père veut dire
regarde ce type il est formidable et
c'était raymond devos
voilà c'est l'intérêt monde j'ai été
nourri au lait du spectacle vraiment
rebih brauner sa première sortie au
théâtre de pierre arditi à l'âge de 7
ans on comprend tout après comédie
française au poulailler c'est tout
binger c'est tout donc ça m'intéresse si
ça m'intéresse savoir comment les gens
sont devenus ce qu'ils sont travaille
bien et alors vous voyez amphitryon avec
hélène perdriel robert riches quand on
voit ça à l'âge de 7 ans sa marque sa
marque pour toujours avez vous appris
votre boulot chez tania balachova et
maréchal évidemment et au cinéma aussi
ça arrive assez tardivement la
reconnaissance mans oui s'ils tentaient
d'ailleurs qu'elle soit pour être tout à
fait sincère véritablement arrivé
aujourd'hui je ne le crois pas vraiment
avec tous les films de resnais vous avez
vous et oui voilà rien c'est monte c'est
mon grand titre de gloire je serais très
heureux de l'etrat je pense tout de même
qu'il ya quelque chose au cinéma qui qui
me reste encore à faire
et si ça se fait maintenant mieux ça ne
se fait pas tant pis je peux lui mais ma
carrière me suffit telle qu'elle est
passé utilisée au cinéma c'est un peu ce
que vous dites là un peu et en tout cas
pas forcément comme il faudrait
m'utiliser cl c'est une aura la paix des
morts celui ya des morts celui qui n'ont
pas encore été vraiment à montrer au
cinéma c'est lamentable
c'est là pour moi la mode et la culture
est absolument vous avez ça m'a rendu ma
piste beaucoup beaucoup de mal là dessus
et bénéfique
c'est sa vision libérale de la télé
c'est une place ont dû mater la
révolution
alors là attention vous savez qu'on va
faire une petite interview mensonge vous
êtes obligé vous qui dit toujours la
vérité
et puis c'est en liaison avec la pièce
vous êtes obligé de mentir vous savez
qu'on ne bouge pas pendant le djing
vous avez cligner de l'oeil à siliana
c'est possible non simplement à vous le
dire il est officiellement de boycotter
ce cérémonial stupide et injustifiée
voilà c'est ma position et je m'y
tiendrai le droit bien alors
politiquement quel que soit votre
fidélité à vos engagements de jeunesse
on vous a beaucoup vu ces derniers temps
en compagnie d'alain madelin et vous
avez déclaré d'ailleurs - type dans le
programme politique et d'enlever sa
cravate
ça me va vous lui trouvez quoi madelin
ba hmad là je trouve qu'il a il a un
discours qui est particulièrement
adaptée à l'époque dans laquelle nous
vivons et je trouve qu'il ya une
modernité est une espèce de fraternité
qui émane de ce discours qui à mon sens
devrait rassembler pratiquement toutes
les couches sociales de la nation c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que je vous le voyez
brézault nettement je le vois à juste
titre d'ailleurs candidat à la
présidence de la république et j'ai la
ferme intention
et c'est parce que madelin a enlevé sa
cravate que vous ne portez plus de
cravate c'est une sorte de manille c'est
là une sorte de mimétisme les mecs en
troisième quand on admire et quand on
estime quelqu'un dont on a envie de lui
ressembler c'est un peu comme pour vous
qui arrive je vous êtes mis au sport
fait du vélo avec drucker
tous les dimanches matins avec michel
drucker se passe comment ça se passe pas
bien pour lui parce qu'il a un mal de
chien de chips très très entraînés ça
fait des années et des années que je
[ __ ] mais sens du terme d'ailleurs et
lui pour le moment ils pédalent plutôt
dans la choucroute c'est à dire que il
nous est arrivé d'ailleurs il n'ya pas
très longtemps d'être filmé par ses
petits copains de la 2 et c'était très
emmerdant mais si j'étais obligé de
j'étais obligé de pédaler dans le vide
pour qu'ils puissent me rattrape j'en
passe il dort beaucoup il dort
énormément il économise énormément
je ne sais pas il ya quelques jours et
quelques jurons mais peut-être que
finalement là alors il est beaucoup plus
âgée que moi à drucker et donc c'est là
où au fond c'est l'alcool dans la
différence pour le téléthon avait fait 5
fois le tour du périphérique en vélo 8
et admiratif x 8 x 8 x 10 7 minutes 46
secondes quatre dixièmes alors une
guerre et john voight forme si pierre
arditi c'est que vous avez vous avez
laissé tomber la drogue d'une façon à
peu près complète sauf les pétards mais
enfin bon ouais une dizaine de pétards
par jour parce que ça remplace les
cigarettes ont fait arrêter des
cigarettes dont elle est obligée de
fumer des pétards
pas de panique tout de même pas
différent et une brise vitre qui est
déjà bien
un parseur du périphérique voilà et vous
avez retrouvé votre légendaire énergie
sexuelle qui a fait votre succès faut
bien le dire parce qu'un produit la
brutale en pierre mais ya pas que ça
donc
mais d'ailleurs grâce à dieu il y avait
cette énergie sexuelle sinon je serais
absolument pas là où je suis aujourd'hui
et elle voit la fin que pierre a
retrouvé en arrêtant la drogue sont
l'énergie sexuelle on vous a beaucoup vu
cet été avec linda hardy à saint tropez
oui il y avait toutes leurs lignes
avaient droit au remords il y avait
nagui avec une blonde décolorée arthur
avec une zone déflorer et pierre arditi
avec bonheur et brûlera défi qui a
démarré on sent l'amour à méribel donc
c'est vraiment qu à son honneur il a
commis quelques erreurs
c'est parce qu'il va jouer si vous
voulez maribel s'il y tient alors oui
marine rima rue belle isle pas compenser
la petite wii belle allure à bédarrides
elles ont la plus vive ces jeux
gaston il a un autre dinosaure il
s'appelle mary bale voilà les cantons
enfant va grandir et qui va te dis à
papa il ya pas assez de buts sur le
plateau que tu vas faire quoi
concrètement je vais faire revenir
donc oui retournez-les en ce moment avec
joyeuses pâques en province il paraît
que c'est surtout la tournée des boîtes
échangistes
c'est à dire que si vous voulez ça fait
quand même une bonne dizaine d'années
que un peu plus même douzaine d'années
coeur barbier m'avait dit que qu'au fond
sa clientèle son public on ne fabrique
qu'en province et j'ai suivi ce conseil
à la lettre et c'est d'ailleurs blier
lui-même qui m'avait dit que je pouvais
justement en profiter voilà l'avantagé
des tournées c'est sa fille voilà et
donc ça fait une bonne douzaine d'années
maintenant que je l'attends de boîtes
échangistes vous donnerai des agresseurs
et intéressera sûrement d'ailleurs un
excellent affaire il connaîtra alors
j'ai l'intention d'éditer un guide vient
le bio il ya le mardi 6 watts et son
graffiti des boîtes échangistes le
arditi avec un âge heard it is hard vous
et choqué beaucoup de monde quand même
avec votre mercedes vitres fumées sur la
route et je vous fait allumer des
cigarettes par des assistants trouvez
pas que c'est un peu too much pas douter
vous savez moi je vais vous dire quand
on a réussi après tout c'est un canton a
du pognon
quand on sait bien dans l'éclat boucher
ils ont qu'à se démerder pour faire la
même chose voilà
on le connaît on reconnaît vraiment le
mag limites de charge
le libéral le libéral ne choque alors
ben on va terminer avec la littérature
et des lectures publiques aussi non dans
les villes où vous vous allez vous visez
du renaud camus où vous lisez du robert
brasillach du nietzsche oui bah c'était
gelé gelé découvert sur le tard et je
dois dire que j'ai eu tort
ouais c'est un manque de culture de ma
pas très bon mais celui là encore il ya
une parole importante à proférer
aujourd'hui il ya une pensée que qu'on
ne partage pas suffisamment et en
particulier dans les couches basses de
la société qu'ils ne disent pas comme
tout le monde le sait et je voudrais
être le le chant profond de cette parole
vous la tendance à atteindre et je ne
vois pas bonne élève elle voulait de
lecture de brasillach sont remarquables
voilà il antisémitisme ça vous choque
plus du tout un fût un temps où ça vous
énervez maintenant vous vivez avec bah
qu'est ce que vous voulez n'ont
finalement c'est dans l'air du temps
alors après tout pourquoi pas hein
voilà pierre dit merci
et voici maintenant